you've probably seen some of these posts
calling for help to sew down the curb
what it means is this hospitals are in
desperate need of PPE personal
protective equipment for their doctors
nurses cleaners and everybody else on
the front lines of this pandemic these
posts are trying to rally people to make
those supplies but can hospitals even
use handmade items and if you can't so
are there other things you can do to
help instead if you have any of these
laying around
you should definitely donate them it's
an n95 respirator mask and it's needed
to protect healthcare workers from the
koban 19 corona virus have you ever
painted your house and bought a
protective mask you might have some of
these laying or out construction workers
nail technicians even people in wild
fire zones you might have these if you
do your hospital could desperately use
them now there is a difference between
dust masks and n95 respirators and n95
masks will block about 95% of all
particle is bigger than 0.3 microns in
diameter so it offers a lot more
protection than just a regular mask if
you're not sure if you have one check
the packaging or the mask itself if it
doesn't say m95 on it it's likely not
ready for protection against the corona
virus so leave those at home unless you
here your hospital is accepting them
that's not all hospitals need the best
thing that people can donate is kind of
already vetted medical supplies that's
dr. Cristina toolless she's a resident
emergency physician and has been
speaking up about the PPE shortage the
people happen to have surgical masks at
home and 95 masks gloves gowns anything
like that that sort of already approved
by the medical community I think that
that's really helpful to donate so any
spare protected medical supplies you
have can be donated
not just wearable items like goggles
hair caps and shoe covers but also
unused rubbing alcohol disinfectant hand
sanitizer and even thermometers are all
very in demand at the moment on the
emergency department we have to keep
both nurses attending physicians
residents physicians safe but we also
have to keep our translators safe our
secretary safe even the cleaning staff
that are cleaning the room safe and so
as you can imagine that's just a ton of
PPE that we need for each patient
encounter no but speaking from my
personal experience I think I
you'd have sort of head-to-toe PPE
Metellus also recommends a website get
us PPE org that's coordinating the
distribution of donated PPE so how do
you spare please do now about those
hand-sewn masks people are starting to
use the homemade masks as covers to
protect their own surgical masks so
unfortunately in a perfect world we'd
wear these masks for each patient
encounter and then switch out a new mask
hospitals are also using the hand-sewn
masks for patients to print
contamination one infected person coughs
or sneezes however the CDC does say the
fabric masks can be used as a last
resort for health care workers when n95
masks aren't available or when they're
being reused which is already happening
in some hospitals a few hospitals have
even put up their own tutorials on how
to make one if you can so you should be
able to follow along if you can't so
there are lots to toriel's online to
show you how my partners were making
them out of woven cotton elastic and
cotton thread for the last week or so we
give them to a local group coordinating
hospital donations hospitals all have
their individual policies in terms of
what they can use and I anticipate that
that could be changing in kind of the
coming weeks or days I think there may
be a growing need for supplies that
people are making at home some people
are even 3d printing face shields in
anticipation of the PPE supply shortage
these are simple to make with multiple
plans already available online including
on the get us PPE org website it's
pretty simple you just download the
plans load it into your printer and
you're good to go
I've been working with one that was
developed for the outbreak in Italy we
have a low-end printer we use for
prototyping so it takes about three
hours to print the visor then just a few
minutes to attach a strip of foam add a
strap and attach a clear shield I was
cutting up foam and gluing it but now
I'm using the insulation foam you'd put
around an air conditioner the straps are
extra elastic my partner had laying
around while the shield itself is just
transparency paper you would use to make
stencils or overhead projector sheets I
generally run the printer all day long
while I'm working then put them all
together when I have a few visors
I cannot stress how easy these are to
make if you have a 3d printer you can
start right now Massachusetts General
Hospital is printing similar shields
they aren't being used in these
hospitals at the moment but they will be
there if the supply runs out many
hospitals are accepting these homemade
supplies as emergency backups and
last-minute resorts in case they're
supply medical gray ones runs out
ultimately anything that anyone donates
I think should be donated to a hospital
so that they can review the PPE that
they are then giving out to their
healthcare workers in terms of ensuring
the safety of the materials that are
being donated matil is had some tips if
you are making items to donate you try
to do Ana sterile environment if you
have gloves available wear them if you
don't have gloves available wash your
hands sterile space is really hard to
come by in my apartment so I've been
washing my hands before I touch any
material I'm working with and when
attaching the mylar shield I only put my
fingers around where the holes will be
punched so my fingerprints won't be in
anyone's field of vision even if you
aren't making anything you can still
help out some hospitals or organizations
have started Google Docs where they can
kind of offer up different things that
they could help with and offer the
things that they need so some people
might need for example their dogs to be
locked or need someone to drop off
groceries sometimes you can reach out to
the hospital and potentially help sort
through some of the supplies that are
donated or providing food for the
frontline healthcare workers can be
really helpful donating books or
potentially toys to like the pediatric
hospitals could be a huge help during
this time fortunately a lot of hospitals
have to limit visitors and so I think
having other things that we could
provide people could be really helpful
even phone calls can be helpful I think
it's really helpful for people to reach
out to their Congress men or women or
their Senators to relay their concerns
about access to PPE it's something that
it really doesn't take much time finally
if you want to help but aren't sure how
check your local city papers and
websites many are publishing guides on
what and where to donate you can even
help if you're feeling sick and I would
urge people for
those that are either anxious about some
symptoms or feeling that they might be
developing a fever cough or or some
other concerning symptoms to really you
know if they are milder symptoms to try
to opt for telehealth and that's a way
that I think we can check in about our
own health symptoms without overwhelming
the system we've added a bunch of links
and information in the description of
this video so you check out all the
resources that I mentioned and help the
people on the front lines of this
pandemic